[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
qui sera essentiellement consacrée ou à
la première année de gouvernance depuis
l'élection du président de la république
emmanuel macron et et pour en parler
je suis ravi d'accueillir jean noël
barrot bonjour je vous êtes député de la
2e circonscription des yvelines vous
êtes des modèles et en mars
vous êtes vice président de la
commission des finances publiques à côté
de jean baptiste du cta qui est maître
de conférences à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en jean patrice
et florence mercadé choqué avocate au
barreau de versailles
bonjour patrice alors c'est vrai que
c'est toujours un exercice un peu un peu
futiles un peu un peu même mais pas de
décès de tirer un bilan au bout donnant
parce que le bilan le tir en bout de
cinq ans mais face à fait partie des
passages obligés à peu des débats renier
ma première question c'est peut-être
parce que c'est peut-être qu'il a plus
difficile à définir
c'est qu'est ce que c'est que le
maquereau 10 mais ce qu est ce qu'on
peut savoir ce que c'est que le mot
creux 10 mhz alors que le jeune femme de
johnny bonjour il intervient de nous
recevoir leurs auteurs oui peut-être en
trois mots qu'est ce que c'est que le
maquereau nisme d'abord c'est un
progressisme
c'est un attachement au progrès et une
détermination à le mettre en oeuvre
c'est aussi une forme de pragmatisme et
de liberté par rapport aux modèles
existants qui guide
qui guide l'action publique et puis
peut-être aussi une nouvelle conception
ou un renouveau de la conception des des
institutions avec à la fois bien et on
l'a un petit peu accusée de d'être de
jouer parfois le rôle de jupiter mairie
tout cas de représidentialiser la
fondation du président la république
mais mais également de remettre chacun
des acteurs du du jeu institutionnel à
sa place à commencer par le parlement et
ce sera le le grand sujet qui commencera
cet été avec va parler justement de ce
que nous sommes parce que beaucoup de
choses liées aussi beaucoup de choses
qui nous attend un mot peut-être
finalement votre engagement vous êtes
économiste de formation vous appartenait
à une famille politique votre père a été
ministre qu'on perd aussi était était un
élu important est ce que justement cette
différence dont vous parlez cette
novation cette nouveauté qu'apporte et
emmanuel macron est temps d éléments qui
vous a fait vous engagez aux politiques
ou est-ce que vous l'auriez fait de
toute façon
oui bien sûr moi j'étais engagé depuis
quelques
quelque temps auprès de françois bayrou
qui porte une partie de vous dirait de
l'affiliation politique à laquelle vous
référiez et
c'est emmanuel macron qui bien entendu a
su rassembler très largement les
françaises et les français et puis les
les
un certain nombre de responsables
politiques autour de lui qui a permis à
cette je dirais cette famille de pensée
de se retrouver dans la majorité et
d'être aujourd'hui un membre actif et
influent de cette majorité l'a donc
bien évidemment que je me suis réjoui de
voir l'émergence progressive des manuels
macron et que je me suis investie
pleinement dans sa campagne outre
reconnu sur sur cette définition c'est
du maquereau nice vous auriez une
définition est ce que c'est un
pragmatisme est ce que c'est
est ce que c'est une nouvelle vision de
la politique est-ce que c'est difficile
à définir
on voit bien ce qu'est maintenant je
stresse et 1 1 un vrai bouleversement de
notre société
enfin en tout cas politique au pouvoir
politique n'est pas que politique
parce que quand on voit sur la
déclinaison de l'ensemble des réformes
qu'il a pu à mettre en oeuvre au cours
de cette première année et déjà il y en
a quand même beaucoup que ce soit sur
l'éducation que ce soit sur la fin la
justice qui est en cours
que ce soit sur la loi trail sur la loi
travail personnel wii la wii la wii qui
me concerne personnellement mais où il a
pu enfin faire des fiches d'aidé face à
soi il a appliqué ce qu'il avait dit
qu'il ferait dans son programme
déjà c'est une première nouveauté est la
deuxième nouveauté c'est qu'il le fait
tout de suite qu'il le fait vite parce
que comme chacun le sait il faut qu'il
le fasse dans les deux premières années
et qu'il va jusqu'au bout des choses
même si les gens ronchonne un peu mais
je trouve que ça ronchonne pas tant que
ça et il bouscule un peu tous ces
espèces davantage sur lesquels s'étend
des sclérosés à moi je préviens il ya un
vrai mouvement
oui non mais c'est valable c'est un
bouleversement bouleversons et
l'immobilisent journée il n'ya pas
d'immobilisme
moi je le trouve c'est une honnêteté
d'abord ce qui avait été élu en faisant
des promesses et illustrait et iris qui
tient ses promesses donc tout ça quand
même un gros voilà vous avez des
contrats d'état
sa main mais il a sûrement des défauts
mais il tient il a été élu il a fait des
promesses
il tient ses promesses donc pour ça
c'est absolument remarquable je
comprends très bien qu'on n'aime pas les
gens qui n'ont pas voté pour macron peut
tout à fait déçu mais si on a voté pour
mac rond et qui tient cette série c'est
vers l'est par exemple ses deux
prédécesseurs sarkozy à épée ya eu la
crise de 2008 qui doit obliger à changer
de politique et et c'est vrai que
françois hollande a commencé à taxer les
grosses a perdu 2 70%
c'était moins lisible et je crois que ce
qui est très important avec le président
macron c'est sa jeunesse sa jeunesse
fait que alain verna il ya d autres
hommes politiques on le sent pas projeté
sur une une envie de durer pendant des
années parce qu'on sait très bien que
dans le meilleur des cas dans maintenant
neuf ans il sera plus présent dans le
public il pourra plus il faudrait il
faudrait qu'il fasse autre chose donc à
théoriser le fait qu'il sait pas si l'on
trouve ça merveilleux
vous aussi vous allez je crois 36 135
bientôt dont 35 bientôt oui parce que
notre chemin est ce que la faire de la
politique penser que ces dons ont fait
carrière dans la politique vous il faut
faire ça pendant un moment je crois que
la conception que nous portons c'est
effectivement celle d'une d'un
engagement politique qui vient en
complément d'une vie professionnelle
d'une vie familiale riche et pour ma
part je compte retourner à ma carrière
universitaire j'ai la chance de pouvoir
la ralentir quelques années et de
pouvoir la retrouver
l'enjeu c'est que nous puissions je
dirais donner corps à cette vision que
nous avons la politique nous avons
commencé à le faire en réduisant ou en
tout cas nous nous apprêtons elle réduit
alors le nombre de mandats dans le temps
il faudrait que ça s'accompagne aussi de
passer mais il ya de bonnes chances que
ça le soin il faudra que liste que ça
s'accompagne d'une d'une réforme du
statut de l'élu pour que celles et ceux
qui s'engagent dans des carrières pour
lesquels il est difficile qu'il est
difficile d'interrompre courra pour
avoir un engagement associatif politique
ou autre que ces personnes-là puise
néanmoins s'engager pleinement en
politique si elles en ressentent l'envi
le moment venu oui alors sur la sur la
définition du maquereau ni ce moment
j'essaie d'avoir un temps un petit peu
différent de ce jeu c'est vrai que
plutôt que la question n'est pas neutre
déjà et on aurait pu ne pas s'enfermer
dans le concept de maquereaux nisme
puisque moi dans non mais adoré des
macros nisme je retiens macron et puis
comme dans tous ces mots en isme voilà
il ne presque une adulation enfin un
système macron et on aurait pu justement
présenter des choses sous l'angle d'un
nouveau courant politique d'une d'une
nouvelle démarche est justement c'est ça
la question c'est est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui dépasse
emmanuel macron qui dépasse sa personne
puisque c'est vrai qu'on ramène beaucoup
tout autour de sa cause de son parcours
ou est ce que c'est c'est un courant
politique qui qui qui dépasse cette
personne et qui est lequel d'ailleurs
enfin est ce que c'est un nid gauche ni
droite différents
de celui que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure parce que vous disiez notamment
que avec le modem ça ne portait qu'une
partie de l'héritage fin est ce que
c'est un centre un des centres est ce
que c'est le centre dont vous rêviez
je crois que effectivement il faut pas
nécessairement regarder le la république
en marche et le maquereau nisme comme un
parti politique de la même manière qu'on
regardait les partis politiques
traditionnels
je crois que c'est d'abord né comme
l'incarnation d'un projet le projet
porté par emmanuel macron et à mon avis
il faut s'attendre à ce que s'il se
représentait mais bien avant ça pour les
élections européennes de l'année
prochaine se dire est ce mouvement un
peu polymorphe reprennent reprennent je
dirais de l'ampleur et viennent porter
un certain nombre de deux propositions
alors c'est vrai c'est très nouveau
parce que c'est beaucoup moins ancrée
dans une sorte de 2,2 dogme auquel on se
réfère est systématiquement
est-ce que ça a de l'avenir ou pas ça
c'est je crois toute la question
pour ma part à nouveau je suis venu au
maquereau nisme à partir d'un courant
politique est très très anciens dans la
vie politique française qui trouve
aujourd'hui un écho dans ce mouvement là
je crois que ça sera très intéressant de
savoir comment est ce que cette ce grand
mouvement qui a été lancée à partir d'un
projet sera se transformer pour porter
d'autres projets et éviter le piège de
la sédimentation qui a conduit les
partis politiques traditionnels
s'effondrer lors des élections derrière
alors on peut prendre les toutes les
questions des jeunes représentent près
de vous occuper aussi des institutions à
l'assemblée sur le plan institutionnel
c'est vrai qu'il ya une on parlait de
verticalité de jupiter
il y à un réinvestissement au tout cas
la fonction présidentielle ce qui est
assez nouveau assez contradictoire avec
peut-être qu'on pensait qu'on espérait
pendant des années on espère simplifier
plus tôt les les institutions les rendre
ce de copier peut-être le mode au modèle
des démocraties du nord au fond il a
rompu avec ça c'est à st enfin ces
courageux finalement parce que
finalement c'est ce qui correspond
peut-être à la fin des français de la
fonction présidentielle d'un côté
peut-être un peu monarchique redonne
quand même à la france un lustre qu'elle
avait un peu perdu ces quelques
dernières président oui mais il faut
bien qu'elle soit un peu un carnet parce
que on peut pas dire la france comme ça
et puis et puis qui est personne qui est
quelqu'un qui passe son temps à
téléphoner à leonard bah quoi mais on
est chez d'autres choses là il faut il
faut une stature il faut une allure il
faut il faut des décisions et forcément
il faut l'un qu'il faut incarner tout ça
et je pense que macron le incarne ça
très bien je pense que vu de l'étranger
on nous on est les gens sont fascinés
ça n'empêche pas encore une fois pas
d'être critique
[Musique]
c est ce que c'est une de quoi une
inspiration gaullienne nom de la
fonction présidentielle de serre que
effectivement moi je trouve que emmanuel
macron rentrent parfaitement bien dans
la constitution telle qu'elle a été
définie c'est à dire que d'une certaine
manière on peut critiquer la vème
république
mais appartenant ou elles existent si on
a un homme qui ne rentrent pas dans les
fonctions telles qu'elles ont été
définies par général de gaulle ça ne
marche pas et ça crée des problèmes et
la france ne fonctionne pas donc quelle
que soit la critique qu'on peut avoir
sur ce régime il faut reconnaître qu'en
tout cas emmanuel macron a remis les
choses en place
la constitution dit des choses assez
clairement elle dit que article 20 le
gouvernement détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation article 21 le
premier ministre dirige l'action du
gouvernement et on à l'article 5 de la
constitution d'une sorte président avec
une magistrature moral un président qui
fait une campagne présidentielle avant
l'été
des députés donc défini préalablement un
programme et donc on a cette synergie
qui se joue entre le premier ministre et
d'ailleurs est nommé par le président de
république ou on a un premier ministre
qui lui est dans un rôle de il se
définit lui même comme un chef
d'orchestre et ça correspond tout à fait
à la définition de l'article de la
constitution article 21 un gouvernement
voilà qui obéit à ceux à ce premier
ministre et un président république qui
fixe un cap
donc les choses sont très claires et de
facto elles elles ne correspondent
parfaitement à ce qui est fixé dans la
constitution et je trouve que c'est une
bonne chose parce que moi je suis un
fervent partisan de la 7ème république
et je ne souhaite surtout pas content
oui j'en suis c'est vrai j'ajouterai
peut-être je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit c'est à dire que
là emmanuel macron prend la pleine
mesure de ce que c'est que la vème
république à la fois dans son propre
rôle
le rôle du président de la république
qui qui donne à nos institutions la
stabilité et la stabilité
on le sait d'ailleurs les citoyens me
demande dans tous les domaines de leur
vie les entreprises aussi elles veulent
de la stabilité pour pouvoir voir plus
loin et le président de la république
dans la vème république qui doit
incarner cette forme de stabilité donc
il y aura nécessairement une forme de
verticalité dans cette dans cette
fonction là je dirais que peut-être là
où le
là où la vème république n'est pas ou la
constitution de la vème république n'est
pas pleinement
je dirais exploité dans tous ses recoins
c'est le fonctionnement du parlement qui
est chargé de voter la loi et de
contrôler le budget et l'action du
gouvernement
on a tout on a tendance à penser que le
rôle essentiel du parlement comme ça
c'est de ces de voter les lois et on
voudrait presque renforcer le la
capacité des députés à écrire eux-mêmes
les lois alors qu'en fait c'est la
branche exécutive c'est le gouvernement
qui écrit l'essentiel des textes de loi
et c'est par amendements que les députés
la modifie
c'est ce mouvement là n'a pas n'a pas
beaucoup de sens et ça emmanuel macron
l'a bien compris il faut laisser le
gouvernement écrire les textes de doigts
en revanche il faut renforcer la
capacité du parlement à contrôler
l'action du gouvernement à vérifier que
les politiques publiques qui sont mises
en oeuvre notamment sous la direction du
premier ministre et des administrations
le sont dans l'esprit qu'insuffle est
président la république et donc le
président leonard d'évaluation oui mais
le président la république a compris
qu'il était qu'ils pouvaient être
al'avantage du chef de l'état d'avoir un
parlement qui contrôlent ce que fait la
manière dont l'administration met en
musique la volonté politique qu'il
apportait et qu'il apportait avec le
soutien que ces mêmes parlementaires qui
ont été élus justement vous avez une
majorité importante l'assemblée
nationale j'aurais été de soutien au
président de la république
est-ce que ça pose ou pas nécessaire d
un problème démocratique est ce que ray
ce qu on ne vient pas par nature une
assemblée de godillots dire qu'ils
votent alors là où on a vu que sur l'ale
frag migration il y avait quelques
quelques
voix contradictoires mais quand même
mais on ne peut pas être à la fois
godillots et frondeur dans la critique
sera toujours fait
dès lors que vous avez un groupe
majoritaire et un groupe minoritaire qui
vient renforcer cette cette majorité la
2 2 pouces est toujours dans le même
sens mais je crois que au contraire les
voies les voix s'expriment très
largement dans l'hémicycle bien sûr mais
en amont également puisque et là bon je
pense ça a été le ce a toujours été le
cas mais que ça l'est encore plus
aujourd'hui les ministres chargés de
décrire les textes de loi qui qui
retranscrivent les promesses de campagne
consulte énormément les parlementaires
notamment les parlementaires de la
majorité
au moment de avant de présenter le texte
au parlement donc les sensibilités
s'expriment pas forcément de la manière
la plus la plus au nord est la plus
visible qu'il soit mais s'exprime à
l'intérieur des cela fonctionnement du
parlement
moi je suis un peu étonné côte
on puisse se fût ce qu'est de cette
majorité fasse tout ça quand même très
bien qu un président un premier ministre
et une large majorité on va quand même
pas se flageller en dix ans et c'est
horrible ils ont plus de 300 députés
est ce que ce sont des godillots sans
majorité il faut la faire marcher
oui à l'orgue et donc oui bah c'est
parfois on veut pas dire que pour
l'instant il y avait beaucoup de couac
s'est passé pour les deux ou trois trucs
sur les sur le sur les migrants
expliquer le projet où nous c'est
peut-être un tout petit peu grincé enfin
avec tout je crois que c'est à 345
députés non je sais que vient il ya
peut-être le mauvais souvenir des
frondeurs six oppositions entre ces
nouveaux députés qui sont nouveaux sens
propre du terme c'est à dire sur des
gens qui arrivent qui n'ont jamais
exercé de fonctions d'élu et où
justement on dit ils sont 300 et puis il
y en a je ne sais pas combien de nouveau
dans cette parmi ces 300 là une très
très large majorité et donc ils sont
encore plus godillots puisque il s'y
connaît c'est peut-être un peu ça qui
fait que on se tient cette tendance à
penser par moi je le pense pas du tout
mais qui a peut-être cette tendance à
penser les manipulent parce qu'ils n'y
connaissent pas grand chose donc voilà
les godillots de la république en marche
au brio de la france sont soumises
député il vous dirait que le nom des
nouveaux députés
et le renouvellement du parlement du
parlement ça aussi un effet alors
peut-être de l'inexpérience que vous
citiez mais ça aussi les faits d'avoir
des personnes qui qui arrive avec
d'abord beaucoup d'énergie et beaucoup
de je dirais peut-être d'optimisme sur
leur capacité à faire changer les choses
donc ça veut dire qu'elles mettent
beaucoup plus je dirais les cabinets les
ministres les administrateurs de
l'assemblée sous pression parce qu'il
dise pas maintenant moi j'ai envie que
mon projet j'ai envie que mon idée
prennent corps alors que peut-être y
avait-il chez des parlementaires qui
était là depuis très longtemps une forme
de lassitude qui s'étaient installés et
puis aussi un regard neuf sur certains
sujets on voit bien que et c'est
peut-être là aussi l'un des secrets du
maquereau nisme la jeunesse qui qui n'a
pas encore frais oui la fraîcheur qui
n'a pas encore pris l'habitude bas de
voir échouer les projets de réformes etc
et c'est ainsi que en tout cas en
première lecture un texte
le texte sur la sncf et là c'est pas
c'est pas les républicains qui ont été
godillots c'est qu'ils ont voté comme un
seul homme le texte qui a été voté en
première lecture à 4 154 voix contre 81
peut-être simplement parce qu'il ya eu
un élan de de fraîcheur bon je laisse de
côté toute la négociation syndicale mais
qui a permis de te faire aboutir un
texte que peut-être plus ambitieux que
d'autres réussi à le faire a fait
auparavant
on attendait une page parce que
justement une phrase d'edouard philippe
qui lie la recomposition politique est
bien loin d'être achevé la poutre
travaille encore laissons la travailler
justement cette recomposition politique
alors qu'il commençait à voir avec
l'élection des manuels macron on voit
bien que
à droite ce travail un peu yann il ya
plusieurs il ya plusieurs droites qui
sont en train de se dessiner et
là aussi vous pensez que c'est on est au
début d'une reprise en plus forte
c'est difficile à dire je je pense
qu'effectivement il y aura enfin
peut-être entre la droite et le centre
droit du mouvement qu une étape très
importante et très instructive à cet
égard sera les élections européennes
parce que vous avez la tête de liste ou
pas bien sûr non non je la connais pas
encore
et je crois qu'on parle beaucoup de
ministres de l'économie non j'ai pas de
l'information que je puisse communiquer
à ce stade ce sera un élément très
important important parce que c'est la
bonne
et même si les élections européennes se
joue comme le dit souvent françois
bayrou sur les questions nationales
ça servira quand même aux différents
mouvements politiques pour ceux marqués
par rapport à l'avenir la construction
européenne et on sait que c'est
peut-être emmanuel macron qui était le
seul candidat véritablement je dirais
probants selon la campagne et que
présidentielle est donc là il ya un
marqueur fort et c'est un marqueur qui
continuent de travailler la droite
puisque à droite on a on a effectivement
il ya des courants différente par
rapport à ce sujet là dessus sur la
recomposition personnes ont alors sur le
couple pour le président premier
ministre
ça fonctionne bien pas bien merde c'est
pas dans le secret des tall est salée
mais ça a l'air de fonctionner parce qu
enfin je tiens quand on a l'impression
aux études des binômes qui fonctionne
avec cette fois un premier ministre qui
pense qu'à une chose est de prendre la
place de chacun fait son vers la place
du vizir basket mais il y avait un cas
de figure au début si ce n'est que avec
sarkozy et fillon qui est qu'il faisait
tout à fait bien le job pour lequel
sarkozy l'avait mandaté enfin je veux
dire
après on peut parler de beaucoup de
choses mais au début c'était ça aussi
c'est
et voilà hélas salaire pareil je veux
dire il voir philippe il a l'air du fait
il fait ce pourquoi il est là et il n'y
a rien d'anormal au contraire plutôt
rassurant joue on a une option de l'inde
à d'un état qui fonctionne mécanique qui
fonctionne par le manque de folie
tout à l'air de fonctionner jean
baptiste or il se trouve que sur la sur
edouard philippe
je trouve que ce cas c'est assez
surprenant c'est que bon un très bon on
parle de matignon comme d'un enfer oui
et c'est 1er et quelque part ça m'étonne
pas compte tenu de sa personnalité
répression caby tout glisse au privé
c'est assez surprenant et je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose parce que le
premier ministre a surtout été conçu
comme un fusible sert qu'on l'a mis en
place pour éviter que le président un
public eye troppo front qui leur est
justement assez en retrait et ses
premiers ce qui doit prendre les coups
précisément et c'est pas anodin
d'ailleurs que de ce point de vue là
edouard philippe soit au front avec la
license avoir sur une accusation et
caetera et c'est lui qui est censé
prendre
est-ce que voilà et je trouve que
quelque part le fait qu'il ait cette
personnalité fait que finalement il
arrive il est même assez main dans les
négociations c'est comme quelqu'un qui
est assez bien connus fin qui est
sympathique qui arriva et en même temps
et changer à discuter et quelque part je
trouve que c'est bien puisque ça
ralentit justement la teinte souvent on
retrouve assez vite normalement au
niveau du présent république qui en
général ensuite baisse du point de vue
de son autorité parce qu'une fois que le
fusible et grille et bien séparés
publiés directement premier coup donc je
trouve ça les vrais partis assez bien
mais il est quand même en première ligne
un petit fake était qui m'a beaucoup
étonné moi je ne sais pas si vous savez
vous a quelle quel effet ça vous a
produit continue les les violences après
le 1er mai
et lorsqu'on a entendu beaucoup plus
risqué mais comment le président retour
d'australie il n'est pas là comme s'il
avait été là on a quand même une
conception très bons artistes de pouvoir
non oui c'était une attaque un peu
désespéré facile qui était d'ailleurs
désamorcer rapidement par le premier
ministre qui a expliqué qu' il y avait
un choix stratégique du lot il y avait
un choix stratégique qui avait été fait
de de préserver la sécurité des
personnes en essayant de contenir et de
temporiser la riposte voilà et je crois
que c'est un épisode qui s'est passé
quand même on a une conception qui n'est
pas là je préfère le voir vente des
sous-marins l'australie que contre les
blacks et je trouve que je trouve ça dit
beaucoup de la faute à ces mêmes
personnes qui regrette donc l'absence d'
emmanuel macron sur le tard dans nos
salles pour gérer cette crise sont les
mêmes qui vont critiquer cette fonction
monarchie républicaine et je trouve
c'est très français c'est à dire qu'il
ya c'est à la fois cette fascination
rôle hommes et résidentiel et cette
détestation tout ça est très bel essai
c'est vraiment dans notre dans notre adn
historique se le dise ça ne vaut rien au
fait que qui sont en australie ou pas et
tout ce qui s'est passé totalement
scandaleux pas non plus entendu sans
rien n'y est pour rien mais ça a été
relativement circonscrites passer à 400
mètres carrés au christ soit dramatique
d'abord pour les gens qui ont des idées
comme extrêmement choquant de voir des
télévisions
meira filmer les casseurs en train de
balancer des cocktails molotov dans un
dans un mcdonald's de voir les flammes
qui démarre nous venons d'avoir tout et
des commentateurs qui explique la rue
goyer vient de balancer un cocktail
molotov ça va bien brûlé là le truc à 6
et puis rien ne se passe et tout ça et
en direct
il ya quand même un peu forcément dans
la chaîne de commandement fait j'imagine
qu'il ya peut-être des gens qui sont
fait remonter les bretelles peut-être
que le préfet de police
alors c'est très bien d'éviter les
blessés bien sûr on en est là c'est que
je suis brûlé pour qu'ils passent but
c'est l'adjectif policière mais comment
non je suis pas un spécialiste des
techniques policières
enfin vous avez eu des sommets européens
dans lesquels il y avait le même genre
de violences est ce à partir de lait
toute la ville là ça a été quand même
ces conscrits à un peu de magasins alors
même si c'est dramatique 1 totalement
pour les prix alors il ya quand même un
sujet qui fâche on disait
mâcon c'est la droite et la gauche l'un
et l'autre
la commission prend quand même des
premières réformes de loi travail de
suppression d'une partie du lit et ses
fours
on parle de la suppression de l' exit
tax la chasse aux faux chômeurs
la réforme du statut de cheminot ce sont
quand même des réformes marqué à droite
et quand alors une libération en vain le
disque dans le drame de lundi
oui c'est un président de droite c'est
vrai que la première année plus à droite
qu'à gauche quoi il ya eu des réformes
françois bayrou il avait des réformes
je dirais de structures qu'il fallait
faire rapidement pour qu'elle puisse
avoir des effets le plus tôt possible
notamment se prononcer en public et en
ce qui concerne les ordonnances travail
ou la réforme de la fiscalité du capital
mais elle s'accompagnait elles
s'accompagneront d'un certain nombre de
mesures qui vont qui vont monter en
puissance progressivement mais qui
viennent renforcer le pouvoir d'achat
pouvoir d'achat des actifs avec la
bascule de la csg en contrepartie d'une
réduction de des cotisations salariales
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
qui va qui va là aussi monter en
puissance cette année qui est je lisais
un sondage sur twitter tout à l'heure
qui est la deuxième mesure la plus la
preuve plus populaires parmi eux après
la réforme la sncf parmi celles que que
le gouvernement actuel a mené et puis à
leurs valises revalorisation d'un
certain nombre de minima sociaux
l'allocation adulte handicapé le minimum
vieillesse est là
la prime d'activité wii qui l'a aussi
vont monter en puissance progressivement
et venir consolider nous nos protections
mais si on veut simplifier les choses
est ce que ça voudrait dire que pendant
la première année il faut faire repartir
la machine économique
gagnez des richesses et puis qu'après on
peut mieux les répartir
est-ce qu'il ya deux temps comme ça
disons qu'ils sont qui se sont
terrorisés ou est-ce que c'est plus
compliqué alors un petit peu mais si
vous si vous baissez les cotisations
salariales
vous avez un effet immédiat sur le
pouvoir d'achat des personnes
l'impôt à la source car si vous si vous
baissez le taux d'imposition des
sociétés aussi vous modifier l'assiette
de l'is f
vous n'aurez des effets que beaucoup
plus tard
et voyez bien que dans le timing qui a
été retenu de la baisse ou de
l'argumentation du pouvoir d'achat
contre la fiscalité du capital la
fiscalité du capital vient avant ce qui
donne l'impression qu'on avantage les
riches puisque c'est effectivement cette
fiscalité du capital va plutôt avantager
les jeux contrairement aux autres
mesures de jeu par les 1,5 non plutôt
avantager les personnes modestes les
classes moyennes il fallait faire les
premières ou va il a été choisi décidé
de faire ses premières mesures
au tout début pour qu'elle puisse porter
des leurs fruits le plus tôt possible
mais ceci dit ça nous exonère pas de
continuer à réfléchir en profondeur à ce
que c'est que notre modèle social et
c'est ce qui va c'est ce qui va
commencer à partir du mois de juin avec
la discussion du projet de loi
sur la liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel c'est-à-dire la réforme de
l'apprentissage de la formation
professionnelle et de l'assurance
chômage avec un énorme effort de
redirection de la manne de la formation
professionnelle vers les jeunes et les
deux ans d'ordre à quoi et puis des
nouveaux droits ouverts aux indépendants
au salarié qui souhaite démissionner de
leur entreprise de pouvoir le faire avec
la réforme de l'assurance chômage et
donc là-dessus ont posé une première
pierre importante dans la rénovation du
modèle social viendra ensuite la réforme
des retraites
et puis le reste puisqu il alors qu'ils
vont avoir lieu parce qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de cb quand vous entendez
françois l'on dira me connaît pas la
crise et la milady très riche c'est
quand même c'est quand même une des
têtes qui prend enfin des reproches qui
prend le plus oui même dans l'opinion
enfin des sondages les abords de bon on
est bien en france on a toujours envie
de mettre la tête des gens au bout d'une
pique trouver des boucs émissaires dans
les riches des riches les risques non
mais sans l'effet sur le fond mais par
exemple vous parler de la réforme c'est
je vois pas du tout en quoi ce serait
une réforme pour les riches que les
cheminots sur les gens les plus
privilégiées en vue sur le bras justin
est juste un accent sur la sncf
non mais juste un instant sur les scènes
célèbres ce combat les cheminots sont
arc boutés sur ce statut et en même
temps ils passent leur temps à dire
qu'ils ne sont pas des privilégiés
alors si on n'est pas privilégiée
pourquoi est ce qu'on a pourquoi ce
qu'on insiste pour garder un statut qui
n'est pas un statut de privilégié c'est
quand même curieux comme non ça me
paraît le privé dédié scola a oui mais
voilà donc mais sinon c'est pas du tout
de réforme de riches c'est là tout le
monde est d'accord mais il répond qu'il
fallait maintenant qu'il fallait non
mais c'est pas là il faut droit
toulousain est dans le pré ensemble dans
l'opinion c'est de considérer comme une
or what fait quelques pertes de la cgt
je crains pas suffi lensois travail
cette fin on a quand même la sueur c'est
un travail chez entier l'a quand même
des des réformes qui sont qu'ils sont en
droit de bon c'est pas un gros mot est
derrière la droite
oui on peut difficilement que la sig la
droite mais vous parlez de réformes des
réformes structurelles de gauche au cifa
serge que et moi c'est ça qui me que je
trouve assez singulier finalement on en
parlait du maquereau nisme de qu'est ce
que c'est c'est à dire qu'en fait moi
j'avais l'impression que le le sentry
c'était une position assez équilibré
finalement entre eux une synthèse de la
gauche et de la droite et qu'on avait
une position d'équilibré face à tous les
sujets quels qu'ils soient
alors que finalement au regard de ce qui
se passait vraiment tendre forcément un
centre et oui on a on a plutôt le
sentiment qu'en fait il y aurait des
thématiques plutôt à droite et l'autre
c'est à dire notamment le domaine
économique pour lequel on a plutôt une
approche plutôt libérale et d'autres
thématiques et on attend lesquels qui
serait plutôt de gauche mais
effectivement pour l'heure si on s'en
tient à ce qui s'est fait et il faut pas
juger en un an
la couleur politique véritable de ce
courant politique mais mais il est vrai
que pour l'heure c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt de droite
non mais parce que vous êtes en train
d'opposer libéralisme et protectionnisme
je pense
voilà c'est ça je veux dire libéralise
de drap protectionnistes de gauche c'est
un peu si je fais une synthèse de ce que
vous venez dire ça à peu près ça puisque
vous dites c'est un peu les réformes
libérales cette droite et donc on attend
les autres il ya en fait c'est
protectionnisme c'est la deuxième jambe
qui devenant arrivée sur
protectionnistes parce que c'est après
l'idée bon parce que l'idée d' emmanuel
macron c'est
comment dirais-je ces deux d'optimiser
les forces économiques pour qu' il ya
ensuite des retombées qui l'emploie et
caetera et que voilà alors alors que la
gauche
ll est bon notre gauche classique né a
fait le reste dans une logique où est là
mais le capitalisme et on a dépassé cela
depuis longtemps mais où on a sorti à
chaque fois ces réformes la forme de
protection sociale du produit des
salariés et sert à ce qui manque un peu
enfin je ne veux pas faire le comment
dirais-je moi je regarde ça avec de
beaucoup de distance il s'agit pas de mi
mai mais il est vrai que c'est quand
même plutôt marqué à droite je trouve
on est à jean-charles dramédie attendu
cet automne une satire un peu avant on a
quand même vu que le centrisme ça nous a
bien fonctionné donc d'abord commencé ce
qu'on a vu ce qu'on a vu quelques succès
qui on l'a vu on a que par la discussion
de la loi zee l'immigration ou pendant
une très longue semaine dans l'hémicycle
la droite et la gauche et l'extrême
gauche on joue au ping pong les uns
disant que la loi était laxiste liban
qu'elle était répressive complètement et
alors après
est ce que est ce que là est ce qu'il
vaut mieux des lois qui satisfasse tout
le monde ou pas là je crois qu'il ya une
position d'équilibré qui a été trouvé
qui ne satisfaisait pas la droite ni la
gauche mais qui a permis de faire
avancer les choses
justement il ya parmi les députés il ya
des gens qui viennent de tous les camps
beaucoup d'anciens socialistes y ait
beaucoup de fins d'aider les gens de
droite et du centre est ce qu'il ya des
tiraillements par rapport à la politique
qui a été menée ce qui a une sensibilité
de gauche qui s'exprime dans les députés
ont marre bien sûr il ya un projet je
crois auquel tous les députés
aujourd'hui élus ont pleinement adhéré
ou en tout cas ont adhéré dans son
ensemble ne prenait pas forcément
d'accord avec toutes les mesures et ça
ça constitue le socle je dirais
inébranlable sur lequel emmanuel macron
peut dérouler sa politique mais une fois
qu'on a donné les grands principes qu'il
faut rentrer dans le détail les
ministres écrivent avec leur
administration les textes c'est que
c'est dans ce détail là que se joue
certains des tiraillements qui viennent
des sensibilités
je dirais politiques antérieures mais
aussi des sensibilités territoriale avec
des sujets qui peuvent être perçus de
manière très différente selon selon les
régions
de métropole et d'outre-mer dès
d'ailleurs et donc ses sensibilités là
s'expriment très naturellement la
difficulté effectivement c'est pour le
groupe en marge de continuer à jouer son
rôle de groupe majoritaire en laissant
s'exprimer les sensibilités sans tomber
dans les problèmes ou les écueils qui
ont rencontré le carreau groupe peut que
rencontrer le groupe ps taylor delà la
mandature précédente où s'est développé
dans un mélange de laisser faire et
d'autoritarisme parfois une sorte de de
fronde qui a sapé complètement le
travail a empêché de gouverner
oui donc il ya un autre sujet c'est ce
sont comme les réformes dont qui ont
lieu il ya là on est quand même dans une
période de manifestations et
manifestations et grèves
généralement les gouvernements finissent
toujours par recule un peu ça on a
l'impression qu'ils veulent que ce que
je la veux te dire est ce qui peut le
faire ce qu'elle est le moyen de le
faire est ce que vous pensez bien le
soutien de l'opinion qu'il ya cf
à nouveau c'est une réforme qui est
assez populaire qui a été très largement
voté en première lecture même si la
concertation continue et que la méthode
choisie par le gouvernement assez
originale de continuer à enrichir le
texte au fur et à mesure de la de la
négociation je pense que
la l'opinion publique ne se retourne pas
contre le gouvernement d'abord parce que
elle voit bien les avantages que peut
représenter cette réforme elle sait que
la l'ouverture à la concurrence qui est
une des raisons pour lesquelles on fait
cette réforme est quelque chose qui a
été décidé aussi par la france dans le
cadre européen et elle ressent de la
même manière qu'elle a appelé de ses
voeux la fin de certains des privilèges
des élus et des députés qui ont commencé
leur mandat par en sabrant dans l'eure
dans leurs avantages et leurs privilèges
de la même manière elle rejette un peu
la tentation que pour avoir certains
cheminots de défendre leurs privilèges
et de manière assez paradoxale je trouve
pour en avoir discuté avec certains
personnels de la sncf
ceux qui sont potentiellement en
difficulté
c'est pas forcément les pas
nécessairement les cheminots même si
l'ours et le statut du cheminot va va
évoluer mais c'est aussi tout un tas de
fonctions support dans les différentes
organisations les différents épique qui
constitua sncf qui à mesure qu'ils vont
être rapprochés les uns réseaux dans
certaines sociétés s'inquiètent de
savoir s'ils seront gardés comment
est-ce que ce quelle sera leur lien mais
il s'agit pas nécessairement de
cheminots il s'agit parfois
d'architectes de secrétaire et ses
acquis sociaux ce qu'on va devenir
et bizarrement resserré ses
revendications la ne perçoit pas je
pense que si elle était un peu plus
audible peut-être que l'opinion publique
je dirais ferait peut-être un peu plus
attention à ces aspects là de la réforme
mais aujourd'hui je ne vois pas ce qui
pourrait
arrêté le train en marche d'accord la
dessus je pense pas qu'ils reculent en
est ce qu'ils puissent y aller jusqu'en
radicalisation de l'autre côté enfin du
côté des services des manifestants et on
voit bien aussi tentative alors plus ou
moins appel à une seulement du pouvoir
je pense que ma qu'on peut dormir
tranquille ccm justamond qui appelle à
la mélenchon tout macro scandaleux ce
que enfin bref
non mais de battre les enseignants
soient partis là-dessus
j'imagine que c'est les mêmes qui vont
au collet d'un whist on peut dire en
effet la fata main qu on peut tout dire
je suis ni même à ça qu'on reconnaît
certaines personnes échec
cette grève c'est presque un peu comme
une grève mais je pense que les français
ont compris c'est un peu comme une grève
de la faim qui serait calé deux jours je
mange trois jours je pense pas deux
jours je m'en serais jugement c'est un
peu une grève qui sert à rien cercle
juste emmerder tout le monde
très souvent enfin je veux dire c'est
pas une grève qui dure 15 jours ou tous
pays est bloqué hier que maintenant les
gens sont habitués des réunions de
travail se font avec ce calendrier ou ne
connaissent pas ça démultiplier une
certaine économie parallèle le
télétravail les bustes inventé les gens
s'adaptent
macron blabla car les les change de
voiture locaux voitures voilà bon ça
peut durer alors oui effectivement la
cgt peut dire qu'on fera après le après
juin fera juillet août et septembre et
qui probablement octobre et novembre
peut-être mais je sais c'est vraiment un
combat d'arrière dans les chiffres que
ça s'essouffle un peu qu'il ya quand
même moins deux il ya moins de grévistes
oui moi j'ai je comprends que des
inquiétudes puisse s'exprimer
face à des changements importants qui
arrivent rapidement les uns ni les
autres
je crois que il ya toujours ce réflexe
du corps social de je dirais de se
crisper
quand quand la réforme arrive et je
crois qu'il faut aussi que
les parlementaires le gouvernement fasse
bien la pédagogie ce que nous essayons
de faire ce que nous essayons de faire
c'est pas d'arriver à un fonctionnement
de l'économie et de la société qui soit
pleinement libéral ce que nous essayons
de faire c'est de ces deux d'ouvrir une
voie pour que chacune et chacun puisse
saisir des opportunités dans la société
il arrive et ça ça se joue à à tout un
tas de niveaux
effectivement ça se joue un peu sur dans
la libéralisation du marché du travail
ces terrains mais ça se joue aussi à
l'école et c'est la raison pour laquelle
une des premières mesures qui a été
adoptée c'est de diviser les la taille
des classes de cp par deux ans
donneraient plus ça se joue aussi dans
la gestion de la formation parce que il
n'est de richesse que d'hommes et cette
réforme de la formation professionnelle
doit permettre à chacun de trouver des
opportunités dans la société de demain
et donc c'est vrai que si on regarde au
microscope les réformes les unes après
les autres on peut avoir ce réflexe
droit hier il veut nous faire avaler
loire un capitalisme à tout crin il
importe ce que j ai dire ce qu'on veut
c'est des opportunités pour tous et
jusqu'à présent ce qu'on a fait c'est à
dire sécurisé à tout prix les emplois et
c'est tout ce que ça a surtout fait
c'est oui sécurisé personnes qui étaient
à l'intérieur mais ça empêcher les
personnes qui étaient à l'extérieur
d'entrée et d'avoir accès à ces
opportunités là donc il faut changer ces
acheteurs de modèles
c'est ce que nous sommes je crois que
l'enjeu l'enjeu véritable c'est de
pouvoir faire en sorte que les personnes
qui sont dans une entreprise puis 7
employables le plus longtemps possible
puisqu'on sait que les gens vont changer
rapidement ils peuvent rester de trois
ans une entreprise repartir ailleurs et
avoir une espèce d'employabilité à vide
par justement toute cette réforme de la
formation et ça c'est extrêmement
important pour nos informations c'est
primordial mais est ce que quand même on
n'a pas un problème alors français quand
face à un pouvoir comme ça là c'est vrai
qu'il ya une sorte de délitement de
l'opposition des oppositions c'est très
bien
pas de vraie opposition enfin on voit
bien les divisions à droite
mélenchon et la faiblesse des cervicales
c'est quand même un vrai problème parce
que ça serait bien d'avoir des
interlocuteurs
oui on peut on peut regretter notamment
que dans le cadre de la réforme la sncf
le dialogue ce qui est un peu
indépendant orthogonale à la à la
réforme fiscale est une question de
survie d'un flux sur vide
en parallèle de sélection enfin
absolument et c'est malheureusement
quand là je dirais quand là et c'est un
peu l'histoire du syndicalisme français
1 quand la la je dirais quand le
syndicalisme faibli le réflexe naturel
de l'état c'est plutôt de le remplacer
de la nature a horreur du vide donc de
deux je dirais de prendre ses
responsabilités et donc il faut trouver
les voies de sans doute pour l'avenir
d'un dialogue de meilleure qualité
renforcée entre les faits dans la nôtre
c'est ce qui est loin travail a rempli
le vide mais oui mais ça ne renforce pas
le savez qu'un petit valois travail sur
sur la carrière des syndicalistes pour
moi le renforcement du syndicalisme il
doit se jouer dans les urnes en termes
de légitimité
serge qu' il faut que les syndicats
représentés salariés c'est pas le camp
français ce n'est pas le cas ils
représentent commencé pour cent donc
pour moi le vrai problème il est
d'avoir que ces syndicats se préoccupent
de leur base de leurs salariés puissent
les convaincre le cas est chiant ou pas
mais enfin qu'il puisse représenter des
salariés et moi ce que je trouve assez
choquant c'est l'importance qu'on leur
donne au regard de la légitimité qui est
la leur regardez sur le débat la sncf
on recule le cercle gouvernement décide
de voilà de recul et un petit peu lâché
un peu de lest pour justement éviter que
ces grèves se maintiennent face à une
partie des syndicats qui eux mêmes ne
représente finalement qu'une partie
finalement des travailleurs et c'est
vrai sur sur beaucoup de sujets c'est à
dire que parce que ce que je trouve
assez frappant c'est cette idée de dire
qu'on va augmenter et finalement la
situation des syndicats leur pouvoir le
dialogue et cetera mais le vrai sujet
pour moi c'est la légitimité
démocratique
c'est la légitimité et la
représentativité de ces syndicats par
rapport à leur base mais la
problématique que l'on a c'est que dans
les entreprises or je parle des
entreprises privées il ya 6 % et très
très peu de sony c'est que 1 des
salariés ont pas très envie d'aller
s'embêter avec une représentation de la
collectivité
donc ça c'est un vrai problème
d'individualisme et m'asseoir des
salariés deuxièmement il ya un problème
au niveau des centrales syndicales où il
ya un vieillissement de la population
qui est très important de joie quand
j'ai des beaux plaide contre des
conseillers syndicaux qui viennent pour
pas assisté des salariés etc
ils ont entre eux j'ai peut-être vu un
jeune qui devait avoir 40 ans ils ont
tous entre 60 et 75 ans et ils me disent
tous on n'arrive pas à recruter de gens
pour pouvoir venir et pour pouvoir venir
aider les salariés faire de la défense
de salariés on ne trouve pas on ne
recrute pas mais moi je suis très
démocrate
si les salariés veulent pas de
représentants veulent pas se lancer
eh bien il faut pas qu'il y ait eu des
reprises des gens qui se disent
représenter la plupart des salariés
salariés pas très enthousiasmant de face
a fait pas tellement rêvé se dire c'est
génial je mettrais un beau gilet orange
une trompette des merguez dans la 2e
partie aux rennais
le lion le raid que l'armée ya tennis
mais ça c'est un peu l'image ça aussi
comprendre il ya 25 ans du combat mais
on a tenu par exemple des projets de
rendre la syndicalisation obligatoire
il faut quand même que le projet
syndical soit séduisant pour que les
gens aient envie de voter pour lui et
pour les deux représentants sais c'est
pas qu'une question david individualiste
c'est une simple question d'intérêt
c'est important parce que justement la
loi travail
elle demande à ce qu'il y ait des vrais
partenaires sociaux et il faut que faut
aller les chercher
moi je fais des formations pré demi
clients qui sont des chefs d'entreprise
alors dix ans mais motivé un peu vos
salariés expliqué leur que l'avenir le
leur et celui de l'entreprise c'est de
pouvoir faire un dialogue social et ça
c'est bien pour les tpe et les pme les
grands groupes ont pas attendu la loi
travail pour faire du dialogue social
dans les tpe les pme sait motiver des
gens pour qu' il puisse avoir des
représentants du personnel et qu'ils
soient motivés dans l'adaptation dans la
flexibilité de l'entreprise qui peut
être aussi gagnant gagnant pour les
salariés simplement il faut que des deux
côtés d'aaron par des syndicats mais du
côté patronal c'est la même chose il
faut que du côté patronal on est cette
volonté d'avoir un dialogue social dans
l'entreprise
et là il ya du travail alors vous du
béret parce que l'activité mais il ya
quand même une question de fond qui
continuent de se poser on l'a bien vu au
cours de l'élection présidentielle c'est
qu'il ya en gros de france peut-être
d'une france qui réussit puis une fraude
plus populaire pour qui s'interrogent
plus qui est qui voilà qui semble qui
semble inquiète de l'avenir
est ce que le fossé entre 7 de france
n'est pas en train de se creuser encore
plus quand même alors il est vrai qu'il
existe un fossé que que ce fossé s'est
creusé ces dernières années et qu'il
faut être très attentif à ce que
certains des territoires de la
république ne décroche pas du du voile a
dû du mouvement de la france vers la
prospérité en raison des évolutions
notamment technologiques des évolutions
du commerce international qui qui ont
tendance à polariser un petit peu la
société entre celles et ceux qui sont
protégés qui ont accès à ces à des
emplois valorisants dans des métropoles
riches etc
même si les métropoles à force de
s'enrichir finissent par faire
l'expérience de la congestion et on le
sait ici dans les yvelines y encore
mieux qu'ailleurs puisque les axes de
transport sont complètement encombré et
que les personnes passent un temps fou
dans les transports enfin il ya quand
même une partie de la poésie qui a accès
à cela elle est une autre qui a moins
accès c'est la raison pour laquelle en
tout cas dans mon groupe politique à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons un
réflexe systématique quels que soient
les sujets d'examiner la manière dont
dont il faut tenir compte de la
spécificité des territoires par rapport
à celles des grandes villes que l'on
pense à la question de la formation
professionnelle avec des questions
d'aménagement du territoire la question
des transports y compris la concision
d'ailleurs de l'asile et de
l'immigration sur des ans lui pour
systématiquement oui oui et pour
systématiquement s'interroger sur sur la
manière d'inclure tous les territoires
dans la manière dont on est dans la
manière dont on réfléchit aux pressions
publiques il n'entend pas beaucoup
parler de l'aménagement du territoire on
peut pas entendre parler tout n'est
d'accord mais je trouve que c'est
quelque chose de fort il ya une victoire
ce qui va commencer à discuter la
semaine prochaine en commission qui la
loi élan qui est un projet de loi pour
le la réforme du marché de fin pour
leurs efforts du logement qui va être
l'occasion d'avoir un certain nombre de
ceux de susciter un certain nombre de
discussions sur ce sujet ait eu la
question sur deux du grand paris express
et des transports du quotidien en ile de
france qui continue de faire quelques
vagues
et puis il ya la question de
l'organisation territoriale de l'île de
france là aussi qui va qui va revenir ça
me file de france n'est pas la france
mais il ya un certain nombre de sujets
de centres périphériques qui s'opposent
déjà à l'échelle de l'île de france il
faut voir réussir à résoudre
vous êtes eurodéputés auraient pu très
occupé si ces valeurs et avec avec un
peu trop d'en parler mais avec beaucoup
de travail pour les mois qui viennent de
la réforme des retraites à la fin de la
fonction publique la réforme des
institutions avec lui les dossiers de la
circonscription qui sont passionnants et
j'ai la chance d'être élu d'un
territoire
dans lequel les citoyennes et citoyens
sont très investis avec l' envie de
participer l envie de donner des idées à
leurs élus à leurs députés et parfois de
leur poser des questions auxquelles ils
n'ont pas toujours là on va garder un
sujet sur des témoignages saint
quentinois sur mai 68
merci beaucoup aujourd'hui le barreau
ici là bien entendu c'est l'inévitable
réunion de des étudiants en comité
d'action une réunion à laquelle a
participé pierre dejean en mai 1968 cet
habitant de montigny le bretonneux à 19
ans il est étudiant en génie électrique
à l'iut de ville d'avray
les affrontements entre étudiants et
policiers le 10 mai 1968 ont déclenché
la mobilisation dans cet établissement
le gouvernement à cette époque là d'un
le le 10 mai a fait un acte d'autorité
qui n'était pas justifié et on a fait le
tour des classes qui était déjà donc
entamé puis on a dit écoutez il ya quand
même eu des événements importants
cette nuit une répression assez dur faut
au moins qu'on fasse quelque chose on
fait on fait une manifestation à bild à
brac la mobilisation ne s'arrête pas là
des professeurs de l'iut se joignent au
mouvement
les cours sont arrêtés la grève est
lancé malgré l'opposition de certains
étudiants
on a eu beaucoup de ont fait pas grève
suspend les gours ce qui est exactement
la même chose mais pour d'autres qu'il
voulait pas s'engager pas ça permet
effectivement da tout arrêter des photos
des journaux ou des caricatures pierre
dejean conserve de nombreux souvenirs
des mobilisations sociales notamment la
manifestation du 13 mai 1968 à paris un
des slogans comme bugs liés scandaient
pendant cette même station ses 10 ans ça
suffit
10 ans ça suffit la société
effectivement très bloqués on palais
fallait que ça change quoi avec ça
change
le changement c'était aussi la
principale revendication des ouvriers de
l'usiné renault à billancourt
jean pierre wolf avait 30 ans à l'époque
il vivait à versailles
et travailler sur l'outillage il
produisait des machines pour fabriquer
des voitures sur l'île seguin
la mobilisation a commencé le 16 mai à
boulogne on a décidé de d'arrêter le
travail et que les étudiants sont ni
bons nous dire comment préfère c'est là
où le radis où on joue à ce jeu là vous
êtes chez vous on est chez nous des
revendications distincte des étudiants
comme l'amélioration des conditions de
travail la hausse des salaires ou encore
plus de protection sociale
l'augmentation générale des salaires
pour toutes les catégories et 7 lb en 7è
le secrétaire du syndicat jean pierre
wolf se souvient du mouvement
l'intérieur de l'usiné
tout comme le travail sur les machines
la mobilisation s'est faite avec son
binôme ou n'a mis nos machines en état
de propreté de conservation du mollet
puis ce qu'on allait permettre le boulot
tout de suite
donc on les a nettoyés mais fallait il
soit et puis on les a évidemment ils ont
les a et 1 et puis on a commencé à
occuper l'usiné entre en août 33 34
jaune me rappelle plus combien de temps
sa bulle on a dormi la borne nice rome
le 17 juin 1968 la reprise du travail
est votée
jean pierre wolf et ses confrères ont
obtenu notamment une hausse de leurs
salaires
voilà soit les 50 ans de mai 68 c'est
vrai que là on a assisté il ya des
grèves étudiantes 1 et à chaque fois
qu'il ya des grèves étudiantes
on parle toujours est-ce qu'il va y
avoir un nouveau mai 68 comme si on
attendait ça impatiemment les les les
circonstances doivent beaucoup changé
dans peu de temps de 50 ans le
centenaire de mai 68 c'est d'accord en
face à un droit un grand truc c'est vrai
que les sociétés la société de 68 était
comme une société très bloquée très
très autoritaire climat on a on n'a pas
les mêmes il ya une rupture de
génération on était entre un contexte
qui succède aux trente glorieuses bon je
pensais qu'en disent complètement
différent d'ailleurs je suis pas certain
que les étudiants à manon se revendre
vraiment une révolution des moeurs ce
devenu aujourd'hui on sait même pas ce
qu'ils revendiquent elles étaient cinq
du société on voit pas trop ce qu'il a
maintenant encore comme véritablement
les avancées qui méritent les petites
anecdotes l'ami de mon fils est en
master de nanterre elle allait pour
aller assister à une assemblée générale
d'étudiants qui était à 9 heures du
matin les tarifs à 8 heures du matin
élan fille était déjà bondée par des
cheminots qui était là depuis cinq
heures du matin des étudiants n'ont pas
pu rentrer dans l'amphi voilà quand on
dit ça va swinguer et ben je ne sais pas
j'étais en train de me montrer qu'il y
avait aujourd'hui at elle y fera des
études c'était une liaison des forces et
en fait il des étudiants direct leur
carte d'étudiant n'ont pas pu rentrer
dans l'amphi y est bien c'est sûr times
cette anecdote que nous allons nous
péter merci beaucoup
florence mercredi choqué merci beaucoup
j'en sors de là je dis et jean baptiste
du clac
et puis on va sélectionner jean-noël
barrot qui étaient avec nous pour cette
émission à bientôt pour un nouveau pas
[Musique]
non